good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Monday it is a
beautiful Monday in New York City hello
my sister Claudia how you durn hi Jax
I'm good I'm you know I'm okay I was a
little hungover yesterday because what
else is there to do and I'm feeling a
little better today you know was one of
those hangovers where you look up and
it's like 6 o'clock and you're like
where the [ __ ] did the day go um but it
went to bed early my new mattress is
like really killing it so I'm feeling
really sprightly for this Monday morning
those are the best kinds of hangover
soaks in you're not suffering through
the whole day if you're just wondering
where it went that's true um I'm like
when you sleep so late take a nap and go
to bed early like I think that's the
perfect formula yeah of course when you
just spend the entire hangover sleeping
yeah
nice well it was a busy crazy weekend
honestly it was half great half not
great have crazy half crazy so something
I wanted to talk about today because a
lot of people have probably seen all the
group drama toasts mageddon on Saturday
was my husband's 30th birthday and we
found a way to get the family together
in a private space that was in
accordance with all of the guidelines
that we have been given up until this
point in quarantine and then late
Saturday night Sunday it just toasts
mageddon descended everyone is so upset
with us for organizing in this way and
posting about it and we want to come on
here and address pretty much every
single mean thing you're just concerning
thing that people have said about what
we did because we did not feel like we
were doing anything wrong which is why I
posted a photo I know been posted a
photo we weren't doing it to be like
[ __ ] quarantine if I thought we were
doing something wrong I would never have
posted a photo and if I thought we were
doing something wrong and not taking it
seriously we wouldn't have been doing it
like if we thought we were just like had
no regard like we would be in our studio
every day right right so um I just want
to kind of take you through like what
led us to Saturday and why we decided to
get together and where we got together
and all of the context behind it because
maybe if you just see a photo that we
posted you think that we're just you
know shirking all of the rules but if
you listen to this show you know that
we've
in colonel iris seriously since January
taken quarantine extremely seriously
since March 13th we've been in like
insisting and trying to get everyone to
stay home and find fun ways for you guys
to stay home and engage with us and give
you movies and give you shows to watch
and like this is all we do is be in
quarantine that we leave our apartments
when we need essentials and maybe go out
for fresh air once every three days we
are taking quarantine so seriously so
the accusation that we are in it just it
comes out of nowhere especially for
people who say that they watch our show
ya know like this narrative that now
we're like the deniers trying to you
know protest city hall it's like we why
would anyone ever think that so I guess
they think that because we got together
on Saturday but let's give some context
as to how and where we got together
because yesterday was a beautiful day in
New York City so was Saturday it was
just a beautiful weekend after coming
off of weeks of bad weather
tons of New Yorkers went to parks were
in the streets went for walks
everyone was put saw an e posted that he
went for a walk with his son beautiful
thing beautiful day never thought twice
about it even if you saw up photos of
parks there's so many people in the
parks and it's like yeah that's not
great for social distancing but a lot of
people have the same idea you know we
don't get that much fresh air in New
York is a beautiful day we decided to
celebrate my husband's birthday on one
of our rooftops we all live if you want
to show you also know we all live within
about a five block radius of one another
I have to walk further to go to the
grocery store or to pick up my
prescription then I have to walk to go
to where we were now we take every
single necessary precaution when we
leave our apartments we wear masks we
wear gloves we have also been in
quarantine since march 13th as has every
member of our family now I know some
people are gonna say but you were going
into the studio so we stopped even
though we were taking every single
precaution and being extremely careful
we stopped going into the studio and
then we quarantined again for another
two weeks before we even thought about
seeing each other then on Saturday we
got together in a private space with
tons of air and space for ourselves as
opposed to going to a park and being
near other people and we enjoyed our
lives as a family um the Commons and
responses that we've gotten listen if
it's not something that you would do and
you don't think
that expired the book don't do it we are
giving taking all the information that
we are getting we are taking it so
seriously and we had one day of reprieve
on a beautiful day in a private safe
space where we felt safe amongst people
who we know are quarantine and taking
all of the necessary steps right what
was so frustrating was like this fake
concern from like people who are just so
evil online like saying these most awful
things and like in our group saying
awful things about us our family our
sister like attacking our [ __ ]
pregnant sister deeming her on Instagram
like how is that how are these two
things equal like what kind of world are
we living in where that is the correct
response I don't understand it like
everyone is entitled to their own
opinion a hundred percent but if you
don't like what I'm doing that's fine
like you don't have to attack my entire
family post our [ __ ] address because
you're mad about something like close
your computer go Amina you need some
[ __ ] fresh air it's it creates a
crazy time and I feel like we are do
we've been trying to do everything out
trying to shirk any rules and if we were
we would not be posting about it we were
not on our phones on Saturday I took a
cute picture of the boys I was in my bed
on my phone
later in the day just going through the
pictures and I was like wow what a sweet
picture I just want to share that with
my followers you know you got all like
follow our family and I never thought I
was setting a bad example um and so I
understand though if it's not something
that you would choose to do if you don't
think that it's fine if you're following
the world everyone is having varying
degrees of taking this seriously
but we thought it through we've been
extremely careful and we had an amazing
day that honestly gave me the like
spirit and gusto that I needed to
continue to sit at home and bide my time
and paint my nails and read my books
totally it was so disappointing like I
agreed like everyone is reacting
differently to this I feel like we've
been taking it really seriously like
from the beginning reporting on it like
quarantine as much as possible like we
have a mom who's older we have a sister
who's pregnant like of course these are
major concerns so this just like
narrative being thrown at us that were
some sort of like animals who are trying
to you know get everyone in New York
coronavirus is so upsetting so silly and
just as misinformation now being posted
all over Twitter all of our Facebook
groups it's like
this is this is insane honestly it's
really really unfair in my opinion and
if you don't agree with anything that I
did
I love that I'm so happy that everyone
has differing opinions that's what makes
this world in this country so [ __ ]
fabulous but like whatever happened to
just like civil discourse like when did
we go from just like and I get that this
is heightened in curtain listen climate
it's definitely heightened like this
sense of cancellation but like what I
think what I woke up to on Sunday it was
like so insane so upsetting and so
[ __ ] nuts that I just don't even know
where to go from here yeah and I just
want to say like this concern for our
sister and for our mom if you think
you're more concerned for them than we
are yeah like we're not we're not dumb
we literally our job is to learn about
coronavirus tell you what we've learned
like we have we know we know a lot we
would never put other people in danger
specifically our family strangers older
people we would never we would never do
that
so why don't why don't we just get the
benefit of the doubt ever like oh these
girls once again they're striking up
their pitchforks and they're like why
don't we just ever get the benefit of
the doubt like that we took the prefer
our own fans it's just so upsetting like
everyone just stinks like every time
it's like we are evil we are evil mad we
got them look they did something evil
they showed us their true colors no
actually no I feel like I for the most
part in this world I mean well I really
do
totally and also I used one a dress like
some of the specific concerns because
people saw this photo maybe without
context you think we're just going
off-book they don't know others how he
says no where was this place how did we
get there did we over there we're
walking through crowded lobbies on our
way there I want to let you know what it
takes for me to leave my apartment I
leave the doors are wide open one
because it's either a beautiful day or I
have a doorman or some of the buildings
that I enter have automatic doors I do
not touch a single thing I'm not walking
through crowded lobbies and then I walk
the two blocks that I needed to walk
maybe I passed two people and wearing a
face mask and gloves like so all of your
concerns that you're that you're coming
up with like those aren't real and if
you just gave us the benefit of the
doubt to know that we're educated people
following the rules and taking this
seriously
you wouldn't be so concerned yeah it was
just like such a disappointing weekend
and like really made me like not wanna
like share my life anymore yeah I
totally understand it's like it's like a
vicious cycle where it's like they want
more and more and then it's like it's
just it's exhausting like want to give
people more and then you give them more
and say they just pick it apart like no
it's impossible and then you also have
to walk this line up okay so people who
are picking you apart are the people who
don't like you and they never actually
maybe at one point they'd like to at
least they say that they are og brothers
but everyone there are people who love
you and do still want you to pose and so
it's like but you only hear from the
horrible people and by the way I don't
even want to hear from the people who
support us because then they get picked
apart everyone when it's time for a
toast mageddon
everyone should stay quiet the group has
just become like this awful place we're
like like Olivia I had to delete like
I'm not even mad about like people being
mad at me like I can deal with it to a
certain degree but like people coming
from my [ __ ] pregnant sisters like
where I draw the line yeah anyways we
have made a decision that has been a
long time coming we are going to be
muting this main group the main morning
toasters Facebook group indefinitely
maybe it'll be a day a week a month we
don't know we just know that everybody
needs a reset after Saturday um I kind
of we stopped kind of moderating the
group yesterday and it was just a
dumbster fire that's what happens when
you guys want to say what you want and
talk about us um so you know we just
don't see all the places and we just
don't see the point anymore like there's
always been this negative undercurrent
in the group where there's mean people
and they're mean to each other but the
group has always been overall good good
things come out of it friendships are
made people are meeting up you know tea
is spilled we don't see the good right
now anymore in the main group there's
great things happening in the subgroups
but the main group has just become a
place where people go at each other and
at us for sport and people have been
going at us in the main group since we
launched it and we're used to it but the
way you guys talk to each
it's just it's not it's not productive
and it's we don't feel like it's making
a positive impact on anything anymore so
it will be muted until maybe there's
just like a change in the way we all
decide to talk to each other until I
feel like my mental health can take it
because it's just like been this like
way where like people just can't say
negative things about us and it's like
if we delete it
we are muting censoring people and it's
like I just don't really feel like I've
shut to sit back and watch you say
[ __ ] horrible things about my family
and then also admit that you don't even
watch my show okay I'm not muting you
because I can't hear mean things about
me I take a lot of criticism but if
you're literally saying something evil
and then also admitting this is why I
haven't listened to the girls in over a
year you're out like that's the one
premise for getting in this world the
one premise for being in the group and
in the community is to be a tosser my
favorite is when people don't understand
okay get out of the main group cuz I'm a
hater and I don't like the show and I
don't like the girls but why the
subgroups okay because it's tipsy
toasters steamy Swifties your [ __ ]
Steen and you hate us yeah and it's like
honestly it's so taxing on my mental
health to just like see so many just
lies like even with this post about our
photo that we posted like that got blown
up 6000 comments the girls deleted it
actually no we did it the original
poster deleted it and she left the group
but like does anyone care about the
semantics or the truth no no no so
that's the decision um we'll see you in
the subgroups real toasters no and the
real toasters this isn't for you but I'm
sure you're glad to see us taking out
the trash for once and for all because
you know what it's enough if the
quarantine has taught me anything I mean
it's taught me a lot of things but
mostly just tell me what's important
what I value what I care about and it's
not people who hate me so I don't know
who the group is currently made up of
but it's really not toasters because I
feel like I used to pride like our group
in our community on the fact that it's
like it's so many different people from
so many different walks of life who have
this innate ability on the internet to
like have civil discourse and it's like
they don't always agree but there's like
this mutual respect and love for one
another that I thought made us so
special and it did but we are not
special anymore like we are reddit we
are go me like we are the worst places
in the world yeah we're the worst of the
groups we're the biggest group and we're
the worst and it's a it's the party's
over
Charles the party's like you
it says oh my god I'm sorry I got like
so choked up I wasn't planning on crying
it was just like yesterday was really
like one of the worst days ya know it
and you know what it's like it was
painful
you think that I would be used to this
because everyone's like once again glad
yeah but it's like there's such a
different thing going on here like when
I had come on and apologized like it's
because I up like I am never too proud
to admit that I [ __ ] up and it's like
I actually don't have a Pitt about
coming on here and owning my [ __ ] which
I've done many times before because I'm
confident enough and and I have enough
pride to be like yeah I [ __ ] up I'm a
person literally yeah I forgot a lot
actually
but with something like this I just had
such a pit because it's like I feel so
misunderstood yeah and they feel like
every time something happens whether
we're we're wrong and we're admitting it
or we're not seeing where people are
coming from where people are just
assuming the worst in us it's like
people use that to say we're terrible
people they're showing their true colors
it's like no we're just showing you that
we're human beings like that yeah we we
[ __ ] up and and we're gonna [ __ ] up
again like because we're just people
yeah and to be honest like this is a PSA
like if you are someone who is easily
triggered by people making mistakes and
there are people like that I generally
just feel like you should turn the show
off it is not for you like I am far from
perfect I probably make more mistakes
than the average person but it also
happened to live under this microscope
that of course I made the choice for
myself to do but I didn't expect to be
so large so if you are someone this is a
trigger warning if you are someone who
cannot handle people but people making
mistakes or people doing things that you
disagree with I really encourage you to
find a show that maybe would trigger you
less because this is not gonna ever be
that type of show yeah and like also
this is a type of show where you know we
say the things that you're thinking or
that you say to your friends but no one
else is saying and if you want to hear
you know the sweetness and light and
everything with a positive spin this
isn't a show for you that's cool that's
cool
yeah but if you want to hear if people
talk the way you and your friends talk
and just having an honest conversation
and and we actually do think before we
speak most of the time and still
sometimes we [ __ ] up but it's just a
little more it more unfiltered this is
the place for you yeah this just this
whole incident like really led me to
like
this cliff where it's like I'm done with
this narrative that we are evil people
and every time we make a mistake it's
like we're unveiling our true colors I'm
done with that I'm not a bad person and
I'm like done with people on the
internet telling you that I am so many
times that I start to believe it yeah
but real toasters no real toasters now
TR TK RT k real toasters no and that's
why we're gonna still do an episode and
subgroups are popping and it's gonna be
great so if you're no longer a toaster
it's okay it's okay
it's not in the words of doom I'll stab
you either gonna are going to love me or
hate me there is no in-between with me
and that is so true yeah it's so true
but if you are here to stay then here
we've got the fast side stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and that's true Jackie but I put on a
little makeup today because our first ad
is so fabulous I felt like I couldn't be
looking like a grey faced Goblin when
talking about cherry this episode is
brought to you by cherry the latest
honest uninfluenced real beauty reviews
cherry is a new Beauty app for Beauty
skincare and wellness enthusiasts to
freely share their insights opinions and
personal stories in an honest thoughtful
forum cherry features everything you
need to know about products and
practices from every corner of the
Beauty skincare and wellness universe in
an honest straightforward and unbiased
way they're devoted to showcasing
product reviews created entirely by real
people with honest influenced opinions
this means users will get Oh will always
get the truth about products and
treatments whether consumers like them
or not
plus they just launched $100,000 future
Beauty fund to support the LA Beauty
community they're committing $100,000 to
local beauty service businesses and
professionals in LA impacted by the
effects of koban 19:10 beauty service
businesses nominated and voted for by
you will receive $5,000 from cherry
additionally 50 Beauty professionals
will be paid to create original content
on the cherry app sharing their talent
expertise and best advice for the beauty
community download from the Apple App
Store or visit cherry calm CH ER IE calm
today to nominate or vote for your
favorite beauty service businesses like
hair salons nail shops and facial spots
that have been impacted by koban 19
winners will receive $5,000 from cherry
to support the future of their
businesses turn it
thanks cherry okay first story I also I
watched so much TV and just content this
weekend I'm excited to talk about in our
TV yes this is Harry who that's brought
us funny this cherry reminded me that I
watched another episode of James Charles
YouTube show when I have a lot of
thoughts okay we'll get into it but
first up the Kids Choice Awards hosted a
virtual show I'm excited to hear your
thoughts but after being postponed by
the corona virus pandemic the Kids
Choice Awards held a virtual telecast to
dole out the slime and the awards
victorious star Victoria Justice hosted
the show on Saturday about six weeks
after the original date in addition to
the awards and slime given out the show
made a 1 million dollar donation to no
Kid Hungry a national campaign to help
and childhood hunger and support people
affected by koban 19 the Avengers stars
Robert Downey jr. Chris Evans Chris
Hemsworth Scarlett Johansson Mark
Ruffalo and Jeremy Renner made a special
appearance during the broadcast their
blockbuster superhero movie Avengers and
Game one favorite movie and spider-man
after Tom Holland was voted favorite
superhero wait ok you know I always roll
my eyes about a virtual telecast but
there's two things that are fabulous
here one is I feel like the audience who
actually would watch the Kids Choice
Awards would probably not mind this like
they don't have to turn on the TV
they're constantly scrolling their
phones like as much as I hate a virtual
telecast or something that I was looking
forward to I actually think like
generationally this makes a lot of sense
and I've heard of a lot of virtual
telecast but none of them that have
donated a million dollars to no kid
hungry so I think that's just fabulous
my only problem here is the choice with
Victoria Justice to host well you know
what okay so I actually saw a lot of
videos going around I think was probably
on pop crave like some of the highlights
from the KC A's and I saw Victoria
Justice like signing herself in her
backyard with her sister I think and I
thought it was really cute and then I
followed up Cameron and she posted her
acceptance for favorite like movie
actress and she was funny she was like
you know I'm sorry Angelina Jolie that
was like when Cole Sprouse beat Brad
Pitt leo
it's like that's what the fans wanted
she was four descendants three and so I
had just seen little videos from the
telecast and I thought it was really
well done I love that they got this line
to people people had their awards they
made their little
Chiz and i think it's way better than
postponing it you know it would be
another six months before they can do
this again and by then it's like let's
focus on next year so I thought it was a
great way and also we just it's a sign
of the times yes I saw david dobrik was
like making so much content cuz he won
second year in a row for like favorite
youtuber favorite influencer and it's
like he's like so famous and like Kylie
gets in his videos Justin Bieber but
like he is so much pride about both of
his Kids Choice Awards like he really
considers them to be like some of the
most his biggest accomplishments but I
just think it's so funny
um and it's cute I mean the KCA he's
like are iconic and they go there for
the kids when we were kids we used to
watch it all the time obviously we don't
watch them now cuz we're big dopes but
like they are for the kids yeah and I
like love that they've kept the
tradition of slime it's like so dumb but
in these like days kids are obsessed
with slime like they make slime they
film it on their channels slime is like
this cultural moment that I feel like
the Casey A's was really early in on oh
for sure they invented slime totally can
you keep talking I'm so [ __ ] hot I
think my air conditioning went off give
me a second yeah I'm gonna tell you who
wants some of the wards favorite kids TV
show Henry danger this story just makes
you feel old favorite family TV show
stranger things favorite reality show
America's Got Talent
favorite TV host Ellen excuse me how
much for that award for Ellen's game of
games favorite animated series spongebob
favorite female TV star Miley Bobby
Brown favorite male TV star Jason Norman
that's the first name from all of this
that I've actually never heard before
but he's from Henry danger can I just
say something like the Ellen thing why
it's particularly strange because adults
are like really turning on Ellen but I
don't think kids ever really liked her
well you know she has the kids on and
she plays her D oh that's true actually
she's like always the first person to
get like a viral kid on it so she has
him on [ __ ] speed dial yeah no she
definitely does but and you know what as
people who like have enjoyed some viral
kids we're grateful but then accept that
yeah that interview she gave was Mason
Ramsay was like literally the bullying
at its finest know for sure but like the
best thing she ever did was know Ritter
oh my god what is those up to those were
the days those were
days that was like right before we got
full confirmation that Ellen was the
devil and like part of you really
believe she was like this sweet old lady
who like loved helping out little kids
who like lived in rural America yeah
yeah now we know the power he was the
apparently kid and apparently yeah
really cute do you want to hear more
winners sure I don't know I feel like
it's an interesting sign of the times
like what the kids are doing ya know we
need to keep up with the kids so like
what are they listening to favorite
movie Avengers endgame yeah that was the
big movie this year
favorite movie actress Doug Cameron male
descendants three descendants three is
trash watch it last weekend I just can't
believe how they [ __ ] botched this
series upon the finale you know how you
know descendants 3 was a bad movie
because even Margo said it was bad like
Margo is the type of Stan we talk about
different types of stands on the show
and with certain things Margo is a
completely blind deaf Stan like she does
not care what you do what you say like
she will love and support you show up at
your house like she just there's so many
people like Hannah Brown she's one of
those people and went with descendants I
thought Margo was that way too like
Margo just loves like the worst stuff
just because she loves the people in it
it's like actually really sweet and
endearing
cheering she [ __ ] hated descendants 3
I'm like oh [ __ ] like she wish she was
right or die a F for descendants yeah we
both were we had two descendants three
viewing party at my house and like it
was all so he just like people kept
calling me and something was going on
and when you're getting distracted it
took us like five hours to watch a movie
and it was terrible also I realized
something about Stan Hood in like all of
this cuz you always say like even
standing means knowing when someone's
wrong and telling them I disagree I
think and I think I'm more on like
Margo's page where it's like I think
standing is like really loving
everything about someone and just like
like the way that I feel about Kim and
it's like even if Kim did something that
I didn't agree with I stand and I trust
her enough to know that like with the
information she has she made the best
decision for herself do you know what I
mean ya know by the way I don't think
you can really define Stan Hood in one
term I think there's like four or five
different types of Stan's in terms of
like blind in terms of blind Stan you
know
like I don't think it's fine I think
it's just like having faith in the
person that you love that they're doing
the right thing I think that's actually
quite quite accurate and beautiful Thank
You Claudia
if you're a blind stand who just like
assumes that the person you love is like
doing something calculated and [ __ ] up
it's like what does that say about you
like you were some yeah and also if you
think that they're capable of that why
do you love them right no that's
actually really true I do feel like
there's so many layers to standard like
some are so toxic but like there's
there's a textbook that should be
written about it I think we should write
it yeah for sure okay I'm gonna move on
from this story I know the how upset
you'll be but um actually we other
categories which is like miscellaneous
social people favorite male social star
david dobrik favorite female social star
Amy LeBlanc favorite gamer s I don't
know SSS Sniper Wolf favorite video game
Minecraft favorite social music star Joe
Joe CY favorite female sports star Alex
Morgan
favorite male sports star LeBron James
cool like what a wide spectrum of awards
like I feel like it's social music
movies TV gaming tech job it's really
like the People's Choice Awards like in
terms of uh you know popularity but for
the younger set I'm here for it the kids
are already up you know there's also the
Teen Choice Awards Brian the TCAs yeah
that's where Taylor Swift like got an
award and it was the weirdest show like
it's all outside at Venice like on the
Santa Monica Pier weird and then there's
also like the Television Critics
Association so some people will be like
I was at the TCAs this week and it's
like you go to the Teen Choice Awards
[Laughter]
remember that week when all that
confusion happened like when people were
posting from the tcas and it's like a
year old Bob Saget where were you at the
Teen Choice Awards
okay next story is really crazy and I
think it's true but I also like don't
believe it Prince Harry and Megan
marquel spill the tea in new royal
biography okay there's so much
misinformation about them these days the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex spoke with
their journalist friends for a tell-all
biography that disk
is there dramatic departure from the
British royal family and their new life
as commoners the authors of finding
freedom Harry and Megan and making of a
modern royal family interviewed the duo
before they left the United Kingdom for
Canada before eventually settling in Los
Angeles okay so I guess they someone's
writing this book called finding freedom
about Harry and Megan and they did
participate in an interview for it oh
that's different
I thought they wrote a book about
themselves called finding freedom and
I'm like [ __ ] oh that that would be like
a weird first move out of the royal
family like writing a book a book would
be fine but like that title wouldn't be
yeah I feel like kind of thirsty these
days it's just so funny like what you
thought people would never do first what
they do especially in quarantine like
Megan joining to zoom I heard yeah you
know what I feel like there are some
people who obviously you know corn canes
not convenient for anyone but there are
some people who really got in their way
of their like upwards trajectory I feel
like um the girls from the season of The
Bachelor like Hannah Ann she was just
stopped dead in her tracks she was on
her way to superstardom
there'll be no paradise probably that's
like alleged you know and like this was
like these were the months when you're a
bachelor could start like you get a few
good months yeah and maybe that's why
they're all working so hard on tick tock
yeah yeah and you know what I respect
the hustle yeah that kind of sucks
because obviously like there's a lot of
benefits of going on The Bachelor but
for the most part none your seasons air
season airs it's just mostly
embarrassing but then all the follow up
that you get like the work the Paradise
the trips like it makes up for like the
shame that you add to like have your
family watch you gyrate on a man on
national television but now that they're
getting on any of the follow up it's
like almost not even worth it yeah no I
actually like feel for them I feel like
they are very upset with the timing of
everything you know what I mean cause
like they must be just rolling her eyes
to the back of her head every time she
wakes up I saw the first talk of her
this morning
yeah but she's taken her towns to tick
tock another way she's doing good she
has like a hundreds of thousands of
followers so we have no choice but to
respect the hustle I'm not gonna lie no
I respect hustle in whatever form it
comes in um also the book is like it's
a biography description says it quote
goes beyond the headlines to reveal
unknown details of Harry and Megan's
life together dispelling the many rumors
and misconceptions that plagued the
couple on both sides of the pond um you
know what I'm thinking maybe I'll read
this it just depends who is writing it
I'll have to do a little research yeah
is it's a biography so like someone else
is writing it about them like what a
loser
and they're participating in it I feel
like when you're at that level you just
like let biographies happen to you and
you're like oh another one unless you
want to like take control and I feel
like now this is actually a really like
non thirsty way for them to get their
side of the story out um because
obviously now that this book any anyone
could write a biography about Megan and
Harry but this one has their interview
in it and it'll be everywhere it will be
popular
it will change like what people are
saying so it's actually a kind of
strategic move for them um to like get
involved with and they obviously like
are gonna they have a relationship with
this person this person
yeah just bash them you don't just do an
interview with a random person like
there's history for sure right
interesting but I don't know I feel like
they could write a memoir you know and
just come right out with it
yeah I feel like not yet I don't
honestly I know it seems like they've
been around for forever but I don't
think that they've lived long enough to
like really have a full book to write
like their story is still so open-ended
I think they have enough to write but
the story's not even close to over so
why would you unless like you know maybe
could be a trilogy totally speaking of
trilogy is did you see that
what's-her-face is writing another book
The Twilight girl Stephenie Meyer yes
she like ended the series but she is now
writing another book it was like big
news oh that's exciting now that I'm a
book person maybe I'll read it yeah but
like begs the question the movie oh yeah
well that's exciting
imagine imagine if we got Rob and
Kristen back together on the subway
she's writing another Twilight book II
yes out on the twice a fam it's a
vampire book a part of let me just get
the rights it's not gonna be about
Edward M Ella like it's probably gonna
be about you know some ancillary
character maybe Jessica you know yeah
Jacob she announces a new Twilight novel
over a decade after the original series
publication her prequel to the Twilight
series is coming out August 4th she
announced on her website she said that's
gonna be great that's yeah that'll
totally be like um about what's-his-name
dr. Cullen yeah what's his name
it's like I'm the tip of my tongue it's
a weird name it's like Esme and uh yeah
just looking at plan watch Peter five
Chapman what's his name
you're [ __ ] Ellie no the duck the
first name of dr. Cullen what's his
first like I'm trying to look it up
Peter Facinelli Bachchan le his name dr.
Collins carlisle karr lyle do you know
you probably do because I've already
told you on the show that according to
Forbes Carlisle dr. Carlisle Cullen is
the richest fictional character ever you
did tell me that because something about
inflation no well actually don't know
who's ever but it's like top 10 um yeah
it's because also he's been alive for a
hundred years and he made some good
investments along the way and he's a
billionaire and that's what really I
heard that Bella was after a hundred
percent they should make an origin story
yeah
that's exciting I actually um I'm not
gonna watch to read the book obviously
but I'll watch a movie I may read the
book now that like I'm into these people
and I rewatched the series um what's the
word for a series of series I guess I
feel like there's more of a um eloquent
word and it's not trilogy because it's
like five movies you know it's franchise
okay I rewatched the franchise a few
weeks ago as you guys know and if you
haven't done it yet treat yourself it is
a treat
I made Ben watch it to when he was
loving it oh my god and even those
movies that you think we're bad about
the newborns and when they go to the
vault Harry um still good still good
well the Voltaire one is a great movie
it's just frustrating because you don't
get to see Rob and Chris
together at all yeah no it's frustrating
but it's still good like yeah I'm not
gonna watch it every day but because we
used to watch try light one every day so
then we're like we can't watch this it's
trash honey what Voltaire hey hair okay
are you ready for our next story this
one's for you because um is it fun for
me is it the one for me brought to you
by talk space thousand percent being
home so much especially during a crisis
like this can be a breeding ground for
anxiety so true me last night without
the stability of our normal daily
routine the mind can fill with the
worst-case scenarios what ifs and
worries you may feel lonely but you are
not alone we are all adjusting to this
new normal for mental health awareness
nas awareness month talk space online
therapy is more committed than ever to
expanding access to support for anyone
who is struggling with talk space you
can get the support of a licensed
therapist from the safety of your own
home and you can reach out to them
directly from your device whenever
something is on your mind you can send
your therapist text audio picture or
video messages from your phone or
computer 24/7 as much as you need to
everything happens within the talk space
secure platform all on your schedule
they match you with a licensed therapist
based on your needs and preferences they
have thousands of licensed therapists
trained in over 40 specialties including
anxiety depression and relationship
issues once you're matched you can begin
therapy the very same day and an honor
of mental health month talks based
online therapies commanded a committing
to fostering a global community around
the importance of mental health while we
may not be able to shake hands high-five
hug and gather in solidarity we can
reach out for support with talk space
talk it out with the licensed therapists
from the comfort of your own home
whenever something is on your mind the
bottom line is that you deserve support
and you don't have to struggle on your
own your talk space therapists can be
your dedicated support system to help
you feel more healthy and empowered even
in these uncertain times as a listener
of our podcasts you can get $100 off
your first month of talk space to match
with your perfect therapists go to talk
space calm or download the app make sure
to use the code toast to get $100 off
your first month and show your support
for the show that's TOA st at talk space
calm I feel like mental health has
literally never been more important than
it is in quarantine and if your warranty
it alone it can feel like you don't
really have anyone to talk to and I just
think everyone needs to get on talk
space it's the
your therapy talk space is always so
great but especially in quarantine it's
definitely exactly what we need to help
us get there like it is so taxing on the
mental health in general and I feel like
obviously there's so many other concerns
that people aren't as concerned but we
are here for you and so is talk space
and it's important it is okay Carol
Baskin was hoax into her first video
interview since the Tiger king release
Carol Baskin has given her first
interview since the premiere of the
Netflix series Tiger king on Sunday
British youtubers Josh Peters and Archie
manners released a YouTube video
claiming they hoaxed her into doing the
interview by pretending to work for
Jimmy Fallon and his late-night show The
Tonight Show the pair lied to Baskin
telling her that their production
company invisible object worked with
Fallon to secure celebrity interviews
for his show then they told her she
would be interviewed by Fallon be a zoom
conference call but in reality they used
sound bites from old clips of the
late-night show to conduct the interview
after rejecting their proposal twice she
agreed the interview on the ground said
she would not be asked about the
necklace docu-series which she has
repeatedly criticized for spreading
misinformation when she finally joined
the call for the interview she was told
she would not be able to see Fallon but
it would only hear him asking her
questions manners who acted as a
producer coach her through the quote
interview while Peters stood by ready to
play sound bites from The Tonight Show
okay look I guess this is like funny
YouTube Carol Baskin killed her husband
like this is like kind of like unethical
it's beyond unethical I didn't watch a
series so I don't know I know like Carol
Baskin killed her husband whacked him
you know there's Tommy minutes can't
tell me that it didn't happen but I
don't know maybe like her husband was I
don't know anything about her hasn't
maybe was a big piece of [ __ ] and we're
all glad that she killed him I have no
idea what people how people feel towards
her all I know is that this is seriously
unethical um I don't know that there are
any laws against it but like then the
article it goes on to quote what she
said in the interview but this is the
first interview that she's done she's
like one of the biggest stars like this
is just really seems really [ __ ] up to
me now you can tell me two people how do
people feel about her so when you watch
a documentary it was obviously very
biased in the sense that they just
wanted to paint it like she killed her
husband there was never really any
foolproof like she was just really shady
around the time that her husband died
and she probably did kill him but in the
court of law there was never really she
was never really considered like a full
suspect and it's not there's no body
there's no nothing like okay not that
you should not you should everyone not
that you should not that you should ever
kill your husband and it doesn't matter
like the circumstance there's Billy was
he a good guy or a bad guy like are you
rooting for her good he was a good guy
well that's why I did it the way that
they wanted to paint it so nobody
actually really knows but he seemed like
a nice guy she totally like wanted him
for his money like the way the
documentary painted it it's the way that
the world sees it now because nobody
knows this random man named Don who died
in Florida but at the end of the day
like she was an animal rights activist
who just like wanted to UM like help
exotic animals and now she's like this
worldwide villain and it's like kind of
sad because there's a very strong
possibility like she didn't kill her
husband nobody knows but the documentary
really just swayed the entire nation
into believing that she did myself
included but like at the end of the day
she's not in jail and nobody knows for
sure but like you never know so I just
think like this is she must be having
like a really bad month and this is just
like a pile on and you're right
something about this does seem like it
could be illegal I don't know what it's
like entrapment I don't know ya know I
don't know what laws there are I just
know that like we shouldn't be watching
this video and so she obviously doesn't
talk about the documentary she talks
about the sanctuary um
about how to do the loss of tourism
rubbing you they'd had to let go about
half their staff yeah but their animals
are still getting daily care because
they have volunteers so I didn't watch
the interview um I just this just seems
really like icky to me this is just like
a trend amongst youtubers of like taking
celebrity name and likeness and really
like [ __ ] things up for them like
remember when those YouTube videos came
out of like a youtuber pretending to be
Justin Bieber and took like really
unflattering paparazzi pictures of him
yeah it's like I get that it's funny for
a like but like these are [ __ ] people
like I can't deal with like this like
total disregard for anyone's like
humanity yeah hey this reminds me of
that yeah I don't know this seems worse
at least Justin Bieber is a superstar I
like you know people are entitled to
their privacy and respect but he's a
superstar and he has people and teams
around him and and money and she doesn't
have those things and I'm sure if it was
someone else like they couldn't get away
with this with another celebrity because
their team would be like oh this email
isn't Jimmy Fallon's but she's just a
woman living on her own her daughter
like encouraged her to do the interview
it's just like she's not a celebrity she
didn't sign up for this it's different
like Justin Bieber has signed the social
contract contract of honey you know
mocked and loved and you know he's in
the arena and we're gonna throw flowers
and we're gonna throw tomatoes yeah
famous yeah and she's just been so true
she participated in documentary how many
[ __ ] boring ask documentaries have you
never heard of no totally and I'm just
surprised that there wasn't more of like
a backlash about this not that I like
want everyone to get backlash but I just
think that like it's a conversation that
needs to be had cuz it's really [ __ ]
up yeah and like the fact that this is
like a top news story everyone's just
talking about they tricked her without
that sort of like this is morally
corrupt I feel like it's gonna become a
trend ya know I have a feeling there's
gonna be like a very strongly worded New
York Times op-ed about it that'll change
hearts and minds that's like how this
stuff happens I think yeah or you know
this toast episode will change hearts
and minds yeah if anyone's still
listening okay next up J Crew has filed
for bankruptcy as the preppy real
retailer succumbs to the koban 19
fallout J Crew Group Inc filed for
bankruptcy protection on Monday with a
plan to hand over control to lenders
adding to a list of brick-and-mortar
retailers pushed to the brink by
widespread store closures in response to
the code the 19 pandemic that is very
sad obviously we've had this discussion
because other retailers are filing for
bankruptcy it doesn't necessarily mean
they're going out of business stores are
closing but it's not good no and I think
it just adds to this like vibe in the
world right now that like [ __ ] Israel
coronavirus [ __ ] is real and it's like
really between like the economy and like
so many people losing their jobs and now
these like major major companies filing
for bankruptcy it's just adding to like
this really unsettling feeling
like not knowing what's going on in the
uncertainty like what tomorrow will
bring
yeah definitely it's it's very sad it's
also really interesting just to see
stores like who was the first to fall
because it's like no company is
obviously like planning for you know six
months of not having any business but
every company is structured differently
so it's just interesting to see like who
will last the longest like who was but
best financially prepared for this yeah
honestly it'll be the companies that
have the biggest infrastructure for
online retail yeah you know I mean
Amazon I literally ordered something
yesterday and it arrived today it's so
crazy also matches calm fabulous
shipping I got two birthday presents for
upcoming birthdays from there and it
came already yeah I got a far fetch I
loved for fetch and they also support
small boat boutiques across the world
that's always been their concept like
you can get anything on car fetch
because they will go far and fetch it
from you know a boutique in Romania that
you wouldn't be able to shop from so
inherently they support small businesses
and they also have anything that you
like would want from any designer and
it's a great place to shop oh and honey
anytime you shop on Farfetch'd honey one
of our sponsors you're getting your
money with honey and perfect I
absolutely love honey this is not an ad
but like shopping we've we have so many
birthdays and celebrations in like the
May June July um months at like it's
very taxing and my wallet and I
absolutely love love love honey totally
okay are you ready for a fifth and final
story is something chris hemsworth
thanks fans as extraction his new movie
looks to become netflix his biggest ever
film premiere extraction is a massive
success on netflix and chris hemsworth
says he's massively grateful to fans hey
guys what's up hope you're doing well i
just want to say a massive thank you to
everyone i checked out extraction you've
made it the number one film on the
planet right now he said on instagram
netflix netflix issued a statement a day
earlier announcing the film is poised to
become its most-watched feature film
premiere to date with people around the
world sheltering in place because of the
corona virus pandemic they're watching
the movie in droves
the movie has a projected 90 million
households watching in the first four
weeks that's crazy it's crazy but you
know what it's like netflix just
keeps getting bigger that like not that
this movie is bad but I just feel like
it's the movie right now and it's like
their next movie will just be even
bigger and it all started I know it's so
crazy
remember the kissing booth was literally
the biggest movie ever watch on Netflix
it had 50 million households watching
and it's like not that this Chris
Hemsworth movie is better it's just like
Netflix keeps getting bigger and bigger
they're like literally one of the
biggest companies and it's like
especially with quarantine on it's just
I'm sure this is a good movie but like
the next movie they released is just
gonna be 100 well as long as it's still
in quarantine I think quarantine gives
everyone the time it's everyone goes to
Netflix every single day and it's the
first thing there is this movie Oh Chris
Hemsworth's
looks good not good enough for me to
watch but you know everyone else is into
it I also feel like buried box was a
similar genre of movie that took the
world by storm and that was also when
people were leaving their homes so I
think anything in quarantine is going to
get a major lift in terms of viewership
like tiger king I do not think the tiger
king would have been nearly as big as it
is if not for quarantine I mean I was
one of the first peoples watch it and
I'm like glad that I got in on it so I
could like post the mediums and make the
jokes but like as a viewer it was
honestly not that good it was so long it
was like an interesting story that could
have been a two three-hour documentary
not like a seven part series with an
after show it to be honest in terms of
just content it wasn't that good yeah
also I feel like other shows like Waco
are getting this sort of lift which is I
think is so great because it's an
important tree story that needs to be
known and needs to be told and that show
is just so good a lot of people are
watching it and I just want to encourage
them oh are we ready for a TV recap
segment because Waco kind of is it a
transition for me is it the TV recaps
Eggman that's brought to you by policy
genius yes there's never a bad time to
save money but now more than ever are
finding smart ways to put some cash back
in your pocket can make a big difference
one way to do that is to simply save on
the things you already paid for like
home insurance if you own a home
reshaping your home or insurance your
home insurance rates with policy genius
could save you a good chunk of change
and the best part is you barely need a
lift to finger to do it first head to
policy genius comm and answer a few
questions about yourself and your
property then policy genius will compare
your policy against options from top
insurers to make sure you get the right
price from your home insurance coverage
at the best possible price
if policy genius finds you a better rate
than what you're currently paying
they'll do all the work to get you
switched own a car to policy genius will
compare your home and auto policies
across different insurers and even
mix-and-match to find new savings
they're saved they've saved their
customers an average of a thousand one
hundred and twenty seven dollars per
year just by doing that so if you'd like
to put a little cash back in your pocket
right now see how much you can save by
reshaping your home insurance rates at
policy genius.com that's pol i cy g en i
us.com okay TV TV recap okay so on
Friday night I watched Richard Jewell
finally and while I will say the movie
isn't great and like it didn't get great
reviews so it's not like a great movie
that I want to watch again and get it
and again this story is so interesting
again before this movie came out it was
a story that I had never heard of it's
really actually sad and depressing to
watch um but just again like seeing all
of these 90s true stories um it's very
interesting it's just interesting and I
think everyone in Richard Jewell did a
really good job it's also star-studded
like Jon Hamm Olivia Wilde Kathy Bates
the guy who hit Tonya Harding's leg I
mean Nancy Kerrigan's leg and I Tania he
did he plays Richard he did a stellar
job the movie is actually really good
and I think it's an important story so
it's now available for rent which is why
we rented it and we Justin wanted to
watch it for a while and I finally
watched it and I'm glad that I did I had
been like intrigued by the story and
like wanted to see it but you know how
like you know that there are certain
types of movies that are gonna give you
anxiety yeah I just know like especially
my anxiety levels right now I just know
that that's the type of movie when it's
just all about like being persecuted by
the media and like having people think
things about you like I already feel
that way I wake up every day like so
scared of what people think about me
like I think that movie would be so
negative for my mental health like I
don't think I should watch it you know
what I I would agree with that yeah but
it looked really good yeah it is it was
good I'm glad I watched it what did you
watch I watched I watched so much drag
race and I won't go into all the details
but I finished season nine and ten I'm
really disappointed in Season ten
honestly justice for um Shay cule like
she was just everything of the sort but
like it's cool like what I really like
about the series is like similar like on
The Bachelor like you fall in love with
people but then like you never see them
again on the show like some of the
Bachelor people come back but like the
contestants like they just go on with
their lives
they're like constantly bringing in past
winners past runner ups they have
all-stars like challenges yeah they have
challenges where they bring back someone
who you like so I just like that it
really is a family like Roo always says
that but like they really bring back
people so you get to see people that you
still like so even if they lose it's
like not that big of a deal um but last
night I watched out of the second
episode of James Charles um YouTube
original instant influencer which is
like a competition show for the next big
Beauty influencer and I watched the
first episode I thought it was really
well done like the studio to make up the
sponsors like it's very fancy and like
they got good contestants but I don't
think I can watch the show anymore
because the judging is false like I know
it's art and makeup is opinion based but
they are wrong like there is a kid and
I'm sad because he's like the youngest
one but both challenges in my opinion he
had the worst looks and like they just
keep sending other people home who's not
diff kid and I think his name is Seth
he's just like not the best artist like
he needs more time he's so young all of
his looks are like messy and there's no
really thought put into it um so it's
just I actually really like the show but
it's frustrating just to watch the wrong
people go home every single week yeah
that is annoying that's kind of that is
actually oh that's not what that's why I
stopped watching Project Runway I know
I'm not like you know the most
fashionable girl in the world but I just
was disagreeing with everyone I
completely agree I stopped watching it -
ever ever since they sent home cha-cha
um yes I've been watching weirdly the
great british baking show because i
remember i watched it when i was on
vacation over christmas because it was
like a christmas thing then it was just
so soothing and you know I don't even
like cooking shows and I was looking for
something to watch just something in the
background like how you have friends and
I put it on and it was it was just so
lovely it's such a nice show it's like
cleany vibes they're all so nice to each
other the competitors like when one
person is like [ __ ] up and they're
out of time and someone else has done
they like help the other one finish
their treats um and it's just it's it's
a nice thing to watch during the
downtime but also yesterday I read
the book for the redheads we're
recording actually the episode today
even though it's really sunk Thursday so
you have more than enough time to read
the book everyone who's read it has read
it in 5 hours or less and it was really
really good so if you want to get in on
the redheads now is the time and I'm
choosing the next book for the redheads
I'm so nervous
there's a lot of pressure because the
redheads has gotten like kind of popular
yeah it's gotten really popular
especially in the queue and we try to
read like we read books that none of us
have read yet so it's not necessarily a
book recommendation club because we
don't know how the books gonna be it's
just like this is the next thing on my
reading list and then we can all talk
about it but I do want the book to be
good I don't want to torture people so
I've been doing a lot of research and
then also I don't want to choose a book
that I know it like it's popular and
good but so many of the redheads might
have ready read it in the community
right like there's hot books of the
moment right right so I wouldn't even
though we've already read it I wouldn't
choose aware the crawdads thing because
then everyone's already read it and
that's not a reading assignment so I
kind of need to find a different sort of
book that might be good I'm taking a
risk on some unknown actually the
authors are probably known but I'm like
their new book not the one that made
them famous and it's just it's dance but
I'm so excited to record the redheads
can we talk about Shahs of Sunset
because I like to walk up on Shahs of
Sunset episodes and I binge like for
over the weekend I was so confused that
it was the finale because it was only
the 13th episode and it didn't feel very
final oh my god I didn't realize it was
the finale I feel like I've just
premiered no I know and I only realized
it was the finale when I was watching
watched happens live he had Adam and
Reza video chat in and then Tommy and MJ
and it was very tumultuous and they kept
referring to it as the finale and like
it's over wow that's crazy so what are
your thoughts I mean I landed um I
landed in an interesting spot because
I'm writer died I had firmly chosen my
spot on MJ's team in terms of the whole
Reza thing and of course MJ wasn't
totally right about everything but she
owned her part in it um to me it's like
the show is so frustrating because two
people that I loved her fighting regimen
Reza and MJ when at the end of the day
it's like not even about them it's just
about the worst person on the show Adam
yeah and then watching him on watch what
happens live it's like he's now
quarantined with Reza and he's really
brainwashed Reza to like be on his side
and they were just like defending
themselves so much I just think like
when they were doing the pottery and he
was like I don't feel safe like we got
the restraining order it's just like so
dramatic and I just I think that it all
it all could have gone back to a better
place if it weren't for Adam for sure
I'm not caught up but I do like
Sebastian as well and and my husband
likes watch so we're gonna watch
together oh I was texting with your
husband I had no idea that he liked was
the Shahs of Sunset encyclopedia oh for
sure he loves it
Bravo beginning all the Bravo shows that
I don't watch like he watches so between
the two of us like we've got it all ya
know I was like he was like what do you
think about GG I'm like oh she's great
he's a cab but she wasn't in the
beginning ya know he's he's really funny
but I need to finish Shahs with him and
then you also need to watch watch what
happens live because I'm Tommy come out
[ __ ] swinging Tommy is so funny and
while I don't condone violence in any
way like I just kind of respect like how
much Tommy [ __ ] loves and wants to
protect his wife and I understood why he
went and did what he did and at the end
of the day he didn't hurt anyone he did
break a couple plans but like he might
have went over there with the intention
to hurt people which I obviously do not
condone but like I'm just having such a
hard time like not taking their side I
don't know why yeah I mean it's just I
think it's probably because the other
side has Adam and you love MJ and I love
MJ and I'm okay and you stand her in to
your to the point where it's like okay
you did something I don't agree with
that I recite rust in you and you did
the best thing given your situation at
the time right like all the people on
the show are saying like she set Reza up
and they look kind of like shady
receipts but like I just don't believe
that MJ like would do that to her friend
of 30 years and and I know there's like
a little bit amount of proof but like I
just don't believe that I don't know but
I know what she would get out of that
she was in the hospital like it just
doesn't make sense
totally but like even if she did you
would think that she had her reasons cuz
you got your reasons
like you when you walked out of my life
and you didn't have to okay anything
else we want to recap before we put this
episode to bed no that is all from me um
to everyone who has reached the end of
this episode we love you now that the
real ones are here we love you so much
we love doing the toast like all of the
judgment and criticism and hate is all
worth it because of the greatness of the
community to cam toast a toast after
dark like the real ones um and we'll
always be here for you so that's that on
that thank you thank you we love you
we'll see you tomorrow